Nummer ett, kapakostnader snabbt kort.
Nummer två, se igenom, hela organisationen är fint.
Nummer tre, förbereda för expansion med varumärk och produkt.
Nummer fyra, våga faktiskt satsa på den expansionen, för det finns ofta en skalfördel i det också.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu dyker vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Kenobi-generationen, jag kan inte ta det.
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag säger.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Lucas från Flowlife till podden och Lucas du skriver ju lite historia här.
Detta är första gången någonsin som en poddgäst är med två gånger i podden.
Det är ju, känner du verkligen utvald som människa?
Alltså Joel, jag känner mig så ärad och hyllad att få ta den här premiären.
Så jag vet inte om jag ska liksom bara börja och sitta med att gråta av tacksamhet.
Men skitkul att vara här, jag ser jättemycket fram emot att snacka.
Samma här, jag sitter liksom och håller tillbaks tårar för att jag får sitta här med er.
Och grejen till att du sitter här igen är ju för att ni har ju gjort verkligen en sjuk resa på något sätt.
Ni har liksom gått igenom Berg-
och Dalbanesegmentet utav dess lik.
Och jag tycker inte att det har lyfts upp tillräckligt mycket.
Nu med det sagt så har jag sett dig lite grann på break it och e-handel och liknande här det sista.
Jag tycker att ditt ansikte har gick upp här och där.
Men det borde gick upp ännu mer för det är fan inte lätt att börja takta på igen efter man har fått en monetär örfil på något sätt.
Men alla vet ju inte vem du är, kan du inte bara lite snabbt berätta vem är Lucas och vem är Flowlife?
Jag heter Lucas Wasznewski.
Idag när vi spelar in så är det den sista mars.
Det är inte bara kvartalet sista dagen, det är också Polens Sverige avgörande match.
Det ser vi vara knappt säga men Pols bakgrund, föräldrar som både är polacker.
Så det är win-win eller lose-lose oavsett hur det går i fotbollen idag.
Men driver Flowlife.
Vi jobbar ju med det vi kallar recovery tech.
Älskar allt som har med utveckling att göra.
Sportintresserad, ser lite bolagsbyggande som min sport.
Där man fortfarande är en relativt ung talang, vilket man kanske inte skulle kunna klassa sig i andra sporter.
33 jordsnurr som man sa i kamratposten back in the days.
VD grundade bolag som är tre vänner egentligen och har väl hänt mycket under den här tiden.
Så det ska bli kul att dyka ner lite.
Jag är inte supernostalgisk av mig men jag har lyssnat faktiskt, jag har lyssnat ungefär halva vårt gamla offstingsplayings för två år sedan.
Och det är lite kul att vara här igen nästan exakt två år senare och liksom få lyfta på locket och se vad som hänt sedan dess.
Exakt, och vad är det ni säljer?
Vad var det ni sålde för två år sedan och vad är det ni säljer idag?
Men för två år sedan så var det det vi kallar vårt grundutbud mycket kopplat till massage.
Det var fotmassörer, fortfarande en stor säljare, flow feet, massagekuddar, flow pillow segment.
Vi hade massagepistoler, flow guns.
Och sist så hade vi precis lanserat och satsat lite mer på det vi kallar kompressionsterapi, vi kallar flow pressure under oss.
Det är ju som byxor man sätter på sig som jobbar med lufttryck, där har vi breddat, så det finns en liten produkt för vaderna.
Men grunden någonstans är att vi lever i en sjukt snabbförändring värld, vi ser att människan är ju den enda konstanten i princip, hur kroppen funkar och vi jobbar med teknik för att behandla kroppen för att man ska kunna må och prestera bra.
Det är hela grundtesen.
Du sa att ni ligger lite i bakgrunden med massageprodukter, men nu har ni ju breddat er ganska mycket.
Märker ni av att det finns en sån här, jag vet inte varför jag ska kalla det, techbrosen kallar det longevity, men att folk tar hand om sig själva.
Är det en grej eller är det bara någonting jag ser för att jag ser det på LinkedIn?
Absolut.
Det är en stor hälsotrent globalt, inte bara i Sverige.
Det longevity är en av dem.
Man ser även marathonloppen ökar väldigt mycket.
Folk vill springa.
Intressant nog, sen de snabbast växande målgrupperna på till exempel Stockholm Marathon, där vi partners är unga tjejer som inte har sprungit ett lopp innan.
Så det är liksom en helt ny typ av personer som vill göra det här.
Så det är en jättestor global trend egentligen.
Och sen har du en andra trend som är teknik och AI som kommer.
Och vi försöker vara en stjärningspunkt av allt det här, tekniska lösningar och kroppen.
Vi ska inte fastna för mycket i historien, utan då får man gå tillbaka och lyssna på det andra avsnittet som vi gjorde.
Men när jag sitter här och typ hajpar upp hela avsnittet för att fan vilken jävla resa ni har gjort och vad det är som har hänt, vad är det jag pratar om då, kan du inte ge mig en liten timeline på vad det är jag går igång på så jävla mycket.
Även om du kanske inte tycker allt är lika kul som jag tycker, vad är det som har hänt?
Jag tror att vi kom som många bolag som är unga och taggade, började växa väldigt fort, fick en product market fit, vi dubblade nästan år för år och sen hamnade vi där var många bolag någon gång hamnar när det kommer kriser.
2022 brände vi en hel del pengar, vi backade lite i omsättning och vi fick starta om.
Det vi lyckades med väldigt bra då var att det gick fort för oss att titta tillbaka till lönsamhet, så att vi började med att gå från att faktiskt bränna mer än 20% på sista raden till att gå plus på ungefär 18 månader och sen därifrån ta nästa steg upp till kraftig tillväxt.
Så vi växer mer än 50% year over year och ganska mycket mer än det och är rejält lönsamma på sista raden.
Så vi har hittat ett sätt för oss som funkar det att inte bara liksom hitta tillbaka till, eller tycka i en hål, utan faktiskt också växa och bygga ett bolag som är bättre än någonsin.
Effektivare än någonsin, bättre produktutbud än någonsin på relativt kort tid i ett bolagsammanhang.
Och det är väl typ det jag är mest stolt över den senaste tiden, att vi har lyckats med det här och hittat nycklar till det.
Och varit väldigt strategiska, hittat ett helt annat sätt att arbeta på vid ett helt annat bolag nu än för två år sedan och det är skitkul att få göra den här resan.
Kan vi inte, jag tänker att vi ska grotta lite i det.
Det är det som är spännande liksom.
Och nu tänker alla, berätta alla tips här nu men låt oss ta det lugnt nu.
Låt oss börja med det psykologiska och det djupa här.
En minut, ge mig en minut med Lucas innan vi börjar.
Jag tänker, alltså du är ju inte en gammal gubbe.
Och ni gjorde ju en jävligt snabb uppgång för några år sedan och liksom fick in en hel del kapital ni skulle satsa.
Och sen fick ni liksom baksmällan här i covidbakgrunden eller vad man ska säga.
Och sen skulle ni ställa om igen.
Att ställa om där måste varit rätt tufft.
Fick inte självkänslan liksom en törn och blev det inte liksom att man började ifrågasätta.
Fan vet jag vad jag håller på med eller?
Alltså hur visste du, dels hur liksom bansade du tillbaka och började fokusera igen.
Och hur visste du vad du skulle fokusera på?
Vilka punkter blev liksom rätt punkter att hålla i handen så att säga?
Absolut, det är klart att om det har gått bra några år, och sen så får man ut med att det inte går bra längre.
Självklart har det en törn.
Men jag tror livet är så.
Alltså precis som om man investerar på en aktiemarknad, så går det ibland väldigt snabbt upp och sen går det ner.
Och så får man liksom lära sig att göra något bra varje period.
Jag är sjukt tacksam för att jag hade ett bra team.
Jag har medgrundare som kunde dra ansvaret tillsammans med en.
Jag hade väldigt bra folk runt mig.
Så de som var kvar i organisationen kom tillbaka och var taggade och ville bevisa att vi kan lösa det här.
Men i slutändan tror jag det handlar om att gilla hantverket.
Alltså jag tycker det är skitkul att bygga bolag.
Jag var liksom 23 år när vi startade Flowlife.
Och någonstans så är man hopplös och optimist när man är 23 år och man tror att allt man gör blir guld.
Och sen så kommer den första konjunkturen man får uppleva i vuxet liv och så får man en jävla käftsmäll.
Jag tror att det vi gjorde bra där, vi satt liksom inte och försökte skylla ifrån oss.
Det fanns ju jättemycket externa faktorer.
Men vi försökte inte ta ansvar.
Jag är vd, jag ibland får stå på scen och prata om hur bra det går och sen låsa att jag gör allting, fast det egentligen är ett sjukt stort teamarbete.
På samma sätt tycker jag att man ska gett ansvar när det går mindre bra som vd.
Det är glad att allt inte är ens fel, men man vill ändå stå där och vara ansvarig för riktningen.
Det tycker jag att alla gjorde i organisationen och någonstans tog jag ansvar för att ställa om bolaget.
Jag tror att vi blev spårade av utmaningen när det gick mindre bra.
Det tog vi sen med oss till att vi var så jävla glada när vi nådde plus minus noll.
Det här har vi gjort på lite mer ett år från att bränna massa pengar till plus minus noll.
Wow, okej vi har räddat bolaget.
Okej nästa grej, vad vill vi göra av det här bolaget?
Jo vi vill faktiskt nå den potentialen som vi pratade om förut.
Och då började vi sätta höga mål.
Men jag tror att en sak som ändå fick ha i bakhuvudet, det är ju lite målsättning.
Jag gick ju inte och pratade om att vi ska bygga ett globalt bolag som tar över värde i ett nytt segment när vi brände pengar och mackade i omsättning.
Då var ju målet snarare att bevisa att vi kan göra det här och överleva.
Sen får man hela tiden anpassa målen för vad man är.
Nu igen är vi mycket mer optimistiska med vad vi kan skapa över de tio åren.
Men jag tror att man får ha den här långsiktiga visionen, man får också ha konkreta nyckeltal ibland som är skitmotiverande om man jobbar för dem till det länge.
Jag vet att du gillar ju gross marginett, alltså produktmarginal.
Det är en sån grej som visat ett mål att vi skulle komma upp i 65 procent från att ha tappat från 70 ner till 55 under den tuffaste tiden.
När vi nådde den perioden, det blev bra stämning.
Då har man gjort någonting rätt.
Det var en punkt då.
Kan du berätta lite vad ni gjorde, dels under den här omställningen, vad som var de hårda konkreta punkterna.
För det är en grej att börja spara in på kostnader.
Vi ska ner lite folk och vi söker upp lite tjänster.
Sen är det en grej att börja skala igen.
Då måste man gensatsa.
Det är två omställningar.
Kan du inte ta mig igenom dels punkt nummer ett och sen punkt nummer två?
Jag kan inte dra, jag har faktiskt en fyrstegsmodell i hur man gör.
Alla människor gillar modeller.
Lucas fyrstegsmodell, har du lagt upp den någonstans?
Nej jag konkretiserade den i huvudet för ungefär tio sekunder sedan medan du ställde frågan.
Men det är typ exakt som vi gjorde och det är lätt att komma i efterhand och bara det här var precis den modellen vi använde.
Men sanningen är ju inte riktigt sån, den är ju ofta att man kollar ju, speciellt när man springer och det är stressigt så kollar man ofta ett max två steg framåt.
Men nu ska jag låtsas som att vi gjorde det i fyra superkonkreta steg för efterhand blev det rätt bra.
Nummer ett, kapa kostnader.
Och det här är ju någonting som jag tror folk fastnar i för långa tidshorisonter, man går för långsamt ner i kostnadsbesparande över lång tid vilket skadar organisationen.
Det är någonting jag lär mig såhär, om man är på väg åt fel håll så måste man snabbt kapa så mycket kostnader man kan så man inte får en långsiktigt nedåtgående kurva, heller ett stort jack i kostnader och tal den skiten som det är för det är tuffa beslut man måste ta.
Alltifrån förhandla med system, måste du berätta att vi kan inte betala det här till att faktiskt hantera personal och annat.
Nästa sak när man har gjort det handlar om effektivisering.
Då kollar man på hela sin resultaträkning och sen ser man igenom punkt för punkt, börja uppifrån och ner.
Okej, hur vad kan jag göra för att förbättra min produktmarginal?
Konkret exempel, vi köpte allting i dollar, vi började kolla om vi kunde betala i lokalvaluta, alltså RMB, vilket gjorde att vi faktiskt sparade ett par procent.
Sen gick vi till banken och kollade, okej har vi transaktionsavgifter mellan de här olika betalmedlarna och sen så liksom går man ut alla de punkterna och kör actions på det, leverans för att handla om logistikavtalet.
Det hade vi inte gjort under två år av högkonjunktur, kunde vi spara ungefär en och en halv till två procent.
Och sen samma sak i något begör marknadsföring som inte är vettigt och så vidare och så vidare.
Då effektiviserar vi.
Vi börjar inte springa än men vi skapar en motor som gör att när vi börjar springa får vi mer.
Och sen kom det till ett steg som vi gjorde som faktiskt är väldigt bra.
Många tror att nästa steg är direkt att börja marknadsföra och försälja.
Men innan det så började vi kolla på varumärket.
Okej, hur stor sannolikhet är det när vi sen börjar lägga in mer performers budget att folk kommer köpa våra produkter?
Då började vi med varumärket.
Vi gjorde varumärkets förflyttning där det blev tydligare i vår kommunikation.
Och sen började vi även se, vad har vi egentligen för erbjudande mot kund?
Jo men vi har produkter som vi har sålt samma typ av produkter ganska länge på samma marknader.
Vad händer om vi adderar till fler produkter som våra kunder vill ha?
Så vi skickade ut en enkät till alla våra kunder där vi egentligen ställde tre frågor.
Vi hade massa olika kategorier som vi tyckte var intressanta.
Sen sa vi, hur stor sannolikhet är det att du hade velat köpa den här produkten?
Tycker du att den här produkten passar för Flowlife?
Och har du en motsvarande produkt i nuläget?
Och där kunde vi få liksom ett delta då, ett glapp mellan, om de ville ha produkten, de tyckte de passade Flowlife men de inte ägde en motsvarande produkt, så var den produkt att lansera.
Och sen sista steget var, trots att man kom i en period där man hade bränt mycket pengar på marknadsföring, vågade se faktiskt marknadsföring som en investering när ni ger tillbaka rätt.
Och så jobbar ju fortfarande hela vår performance marketing, alltså Google och Metas, Instagram och Facebook, är ju driven av en procent av omsättningen, så att går det bra skalar den upp, går den dåligt skalar den ner, och har väldigt rörlig marknadsföring där man vågar trycka på.
Nummer ett, kapa kostnader snabbt och fort.
Nummer två, se igenom hur hela organisationen effektiviserar.
Nummer tre, förbereda för expansion med varumärke och produkt.
Och nummer fyra, våga faktiskt satsa på den expansionen, för det finns ofta en skalfördel i det också.
Fan Lucas, vi kan stänga ner här, folk får bara gå hem och lösa detta.
Det är väl inga konstigheter.
Fan vad nice.
Vi får lägga upp den här, det får bli en Wikipedia-post, Lucas 4-stegs raket eller något sånt där.
Men jag gillar några punkter som...
För man skulle kunna säga att flera av dem säger folk, men jag tror att några saker är lätt att missa.
Jag gillar det du säger med att kapa kostnader fort.
Det är lätt att man liksom, ah, nu ska vi fokusera på fraktkostnader, det är en månad.
Nu ska vi fokusera på system, det är en månad.
Nej, vi ska göra allting dag ett och två.
Och sen får man liksom hantera relationer i fyra månader.
Men jag gillar det.
Jag gillar det.
Och den att ni skickade ut, de svaren som ni fick på den här enkäten med produkter, hur många av de produkterna kunde ni faktiskt lansera och har de gett resultat?
Typ hälften faktiskt.
Så det är ju riktigt många.
Ja men det var också, det var ju rätt strategi, det var ju produkter som jag visste att vi kunde lansera också många av dem.
Så ja, sen vissa hade vi inte gjort än, och vissa började komma nu och bara väntade.
Där fick vi väldigt högt svar på.
Och det är ju hur brett klarar brandet av att bli liksom.
Och ni har ju gjort en ganska kraftig utveckling.
Då, eller vad man ska säga kanske inte när vi snackade sist, men om man skulle säga två år innan det, då var det ju väldigt tydligt de här flow-pillows och sen kanske massagepistolen och sådär.
Men nu är ni ju, jag ska inte säga att de är undanjumda på hemsidan, men de är liksom bara en vertikal av kanske typ sex vertikaler.
Det är ju mycket mycket bredare nu.
Är det det som är själva tillväxten eller vad är tillväxtsteget så att säga?
Det är definitivt jätteviktigt att vi har flera kategorier att stå på.
Och där kör jag också medskick för många som man upplever sin första framgång i en produktkategori, man har en product market fit.
Det som ofta händer är ju att världen förändras och man måste reagera för sent.
Nej, det är en del av det.
Men det är också, vill du ha en till modell när vi ändå pratar?
Ja, ja, jag vill ha en till.
Fan, jag vill ha fem till modeller, jag vill inte ha något annat.
Det är ju kul för att jag insåg, jag är ju inte så billig av mig egentligen.
Jag tror att jag är som en person, så gillar jag att prata men min festival är ju väldigt billig.
Så jag tror att jag har tränats i att prata i modeller för när vi pratar så brukar jag kommunicera så det har jag ju tagit över mig till businesslivet också.
Men någonstans, vi vill ju ha growth, det vill vi ha, vi vill ha ny försäljning.
Så vi delar upp det i tre steg.
Det ena är produkt.
Vad kan vi göra på produkter?
Kan vi bredda produkter?
Kan vi sälja fler produkter?
Men någonstans behöver vi ju sälja x antal produkter.
Då är det rätt lätt att addera till nya skrun, så nya produkter, nya kategorier.
Sen kollar vi på marknader, så gör vi likadant där.
Okej vilka marknader säljer vi på nu?
Vad händer om vi adderar till en marknad?
Vad kostar den för det?
Och sist så kollar vi på säljkanaler.
Så för oss är det våra tre growth drivers.
Är det B2B, är det D2C, vi lade få in ungefär ett års till en ny kanal som vi kallar resellers, som är typ sjukgymnaster, kliniker, alltså typ proffsspecialister som säljer våra produkter.
Inte världens högsta volymer, men ger också en marknadstrovärdighet.
Då lyft vi till en till säljkanal.
Så det vi försöker göra är att kolla på de här growth drivers och sen jämföra var får vi mest utväxling.
Så i början, för två år sen när vi pratade sist här på podden, då var det väldigt tydligt för oss att vi hade inte så stark kassa, vi hade bränt massa pengar, vi hade bränt oss på fingrarna.
Världsläget var fortfarande riktigt dåligt finansiellt.
Och då var det tydligt för oss att vi behöver jobba med typ samma kunder på samma marknader, det finns inga nya kanaler vi liksom kan gå in i.
Vi behöver hitta nya produkter.
Och då gjorde vi det för att växa.
Så växte vi typ 50 procent på det.
Och sådant är det inte som vi väntar, nu behöver vi växa ännu mer och vi har ännu större ambitioner.
Vad gör vi då?
Jo, vi adderar till marknader.
Så för typ ganska exakt ett år sedan, typ tio månader sedan, om man ska vara mer noggrann, så började vi sälja i hela Europa.
Så nu är vår expansion vår största growth driver istället för produkter.
Men de samspelar är väldigt bra.
Men sålde inte ni internationellt innan?
Väldigt små volymer.
Vi, ja, nu gör vi annonsering i hela Europa.
Ni känns väldigt internationella och ni har gjort en del samarbeten vill jag minnas.
Men okej, det är bara att jag har fått den känslan att ni säljer till hela Europa innan.
Okej, vad spännande.
Det är typ ett år sen vi började på allvar.
Det är ändå relativt nytt.
Och sen gick ni in i lite resellers också.
Exakt.
Är det en grej som låter bra men som egentligen mest är problem och krångel och jobbigt?
Jag tror att vi har en kollega som är dedikerad till det och hon säljer och når budget och lite till hela tiden.
Så jag tror att det är bra.
Sen är det inte samma volymer en reseller kontra en distributör.
Men en reseller är ofta offline.
Det är ofta trovärdigt så den kanibaliserar inte heller på samma sätt som en distributör gör om det finns online på ett ställe till i samma marknad och driver inte lika mycket nyförsäljning.
Så som du pratar när du går igenom, det låter ju väldigt, jag känner ju att fan vad jag låter Bonny liksom.
Jag tänker att det är gött att sälja utrustning mer.
Du var rätt tidig, det är inte så att du har någon management, du har ju inte jobbat inom investmentbolag i 20 år innan detta.
Vad kommer strategierna och det här ifrån?
Jag vill bara disclaimer Joel, du är så extremt kunnig och du är så mycket mer kunnig än du är ibland.
Tillkänna gerier för att vara.
Vi har två regler i den här podden.
Ett är att gästen får skryta och det andra är att vi inte pratar om mig.
Så inget sånt.
Jag hade ju hela min plan var att halvvägs igenom bara vända och intervjua dig istället.
Nej, inget sånt.
Men vad kommer allt det snacket ifrån?
Eller insikterna då?
Ja men för mig var det nog att jag drer bolag på ett sätt första gången och det finns inget rätt eller fel tror jag.
Det är bara en filosofi och såhär vi fick uppleva en del utmaningar och då tänkte jag, okej, hur kan jag göra det här på ett annat sätt så att det blir ännu bättre?
Och då fick jag ju lära mig.
Jag fick in en styrelse då, vilka fick jag i två väldigt, väldigt kompetenta herrar som har bylag i sina synvinklar och kommer från liksom större bolag och då fick jag försöka lära mig det arbetssättet.
Jag kommer ihåg någonstans såhär, jag har ju alltid varit väldigt hands-on men då kommer en av de att säga såhär, egentligen som vd ska du kunna sitta på ditt landställe och styra bolaget om du gör det på rätt sätt och jag fattade ingenting, jag tyckte det var helt galet.
Jag tror inte jag är liksom fullt där, jag har inte heller den ambitionen just nu men jag vill få anamma ett arbetssätt som är här anpassat för hur ett större bolag jobbar och blivit liksom utmanande i det.
Sen tycker jag det är sjukt kul att lära sig så att såhär, jag har fått lära mig väldigt mycket.
Jag visste inte vad Grossmart, jag kommer att vara, det var också, det här var slutet på 2021, så vi bjuder på en julfest och sådant stort svenskt investmentbolag och så var det de som satt bredvid mig som frågade ja fan ni måste ha jättebra GM1, och jag fick liksom tugga på mobilen och bara GM1, det är produktmarginal i liksom man har väl fått lära sig för att hänga med i den här liksom svängen och jag tycker det är sjukt intressant med bolagsbyggande.
Sen är jag liksom fortfarande rätt människor-orienterad, jag tycker den biten är sjukt intressant.
Men jag gillar att förstå saker, jag gillar när jag liksom som förr så kollade jag brutalt mycket dokumentärer och alltid varit ganska kundskapssökande.
Och eftersom jag inte har pluggat ekonomi eller jobbat på någon stort managementbolag så vill jag ändå, jag vill inte kunna förstå den världen utan att liksom ha varit där.
Jag tänker, jag plöjer av lite nördfrågor här, det blir lite spretigt men det är för att det är intressant.
Eftersom ni har breddat er assortiment ganska brett och hamnat liksom, jag fattar att man kan säga att allting är någon sorts rehab tech, alltså om man ska lägga det under någon sorts umbrella.
Men det är ju väldigt olika produkter.
Hur, vad är det som avgör, hur bestämmer ni vilka produkter som får vara kvar och vilka som inte får vara kvar?
Har ni några fasta mättal eller är det bara en känsla?
För vissa är ju svindyra och vissa, de kanske bara säljer två gånger per år, typ stora jävla badkar för is eller liknande.
Vad är det som avgör om en produkt får vara kvar eller inte?
Det är en kombination, det ena är såklart, tjänar vi pengar på det.
Det är väl väldigt högst upp och längst upp.
Har vi marginal, har vi volym på det.
Nästan handlar det om lagar och omsättningsfastighet.
Hur många gånger kan vi omsätta den här produkten så att den blir självfinansierande?
Om det är en så låg mock, alltså MOQ, Minimum Order Quantity, på en produkt som gör att vi bara kan sälja ett lass per år så är den inte värd att ha.
Vi måste minst omsätta den två gånger per år.
Det beror på att den ska finansiera sig själv.
Vi har väldigt mycket försäljning i slutet av året kopplat till jul och black week och den perioden.
Vi vill gärna kunna sälja en lass under första halvan av året och sedan finansiera inköpet för andra halvan.
Och sen sista är det mjuka, magkänsla, branding, hela den biten.
Det finns vissa produkter som vi inte säljer lika mycket men de förstärker varumärket och får vara kvar.
Men vissa produkter är där ett och annat syfte.
Vi säljer mycket dyra produkter nu.
Vi har produkten som kostar 160 000, som är fantastiska, och vi börjar märka att vi kan sälja på den här höga prispunkten.
Sedan lanserade vi vår billigaste tekniska produkt, som är en liten boll som vibrerar för 990 kronor.
Sedan märkte vi att vi kan sälja jättemycket sådana.
Vad är rätt och vad är fel, ingen aning.
Det är liksom vår grej i bredden.
Du ska kunna gå in lite spontant, inte veta exakt vad du vill ha, hitta en produkt för runt en tusen lapp, kanske hitta en present.
Du ska också kunna veta att om du vill ha en Hyperbarque Oxygen Chamber eller ett spad av riktigt hög kvalitet, så ska du kunna lita på brandet FloLifo och gå in där och köpa.
Så ja, vi måste tjäna pengar på produkten, den måste bära sitt eget lager inför högsäsongen och den måste på ett sätt passa med brandet.
Inte två gånger per år, inte det lite långsam lageromsättningshastighet.
Jo, jag hade velat ha det ännu högre, men det var en form av minimumkrav.
I alla fall i början, sen vissa produkter är mycket högre.
Vissa produkter är inte där än, då får de lite tid på sig.
Nu har ni liksom uppenbart börjat skala upp igen och liksom växer ganska fort.
Finns det några såhär misstag som ni gjorde första gången som du verkligen undviker denna gången?
Finns det några såhär verkligen konkreta punkter?
Det här, det här, det här aktar vi oss för.
Det finns väl en sådan sak i att förut så, vi säljer inte riktigt hälften, men nästan hälften i det sista kvartalet, alltså oktober till december.
Förut så hade vi två saker, dels så byggde vi organisation och byggde kostnadskostym för att kunna hantera högsäsongen.
Det tror jag är helt fel.
Det gjorde att vi inte var lönsamma fram till den perioden så om vi inte lyckades i slutet på året så var det liksom, då var det inget kul.
Och det var ju det som hände när vi brände oss.
Vi byggde ju för att kunna göra massa saker och sen fick vi dra i handbromsen när världen ställde om.
Det är nummer ett, nu bygger vi i stället för att hantera lågsäsongen och sen adderar vi till partners och ser till att vi var riktigt lönsamma under högsäsongen.
Och sen nummer två är ju inte det egentligen kopplat till samma sak.
Gå och vänta på att tiden ska lösa våra problem.
Alltså oavsett om det är högsäsong eller konjunkturjusteringar.
Vi var väldigt noga med när det var lågkonjunktur på riktigt, för det var det 2022.
Det var ju svårt att minnas tillbaka, men det var ju kaos i handelsvärlden.
Och folk privatekonomiskt hade det tufft med hyror eller med räntor och med elkostnader och så vidare.
Så bestämde vi istället, vi ska se till att vi kan klara av att vara ett riktigt bra bolag under riktigt tuffa förutsättningar.
Så att vi kan vara ett ämne bättre bolag när det blir bra förutsättningar.
För att man vet ju den här härliga världen så är det alltid något skit som händer någonstans.
Att be prepared for the worst istället för att hoppas på det bästa.
Angående det här att bygga för vad ska vi kalla det då?
Vardan snarare än för högsäsong.
Jag köper det men hur fan löser ni högsäsong då?
Det är ju fint att säga såhär, ja alla får jobba lite hårdare.
Absolut.
Det är en grej att säga.
Hur löser ni den grejen?
Jag tror, i ärlighetens namn så var det nog så, första året var det nog så för då hade vi inte heller finansiella medel eller vi hade inte riskbenägenhet att ta in folk under högsäsongen som jobbar extra.
Nu är det lite annorlunda för nu kan vi ju faktiskt, nu jobbar vi med partners, alltså till väldigt mycket.
Vi är ju större nu än någonsin, jag tror vi är 20% plus bättre än vad vi någonsin har varit Rullande 12, men vi är ju mindre än halva timmet än vi var sist vi var ens nära de här nivåerna.
Så vi är ett mindre team men vi har mycket bättre partners som vi kan skruva på.
Och oavsett om det är contentproduktion eller performance marketing eller vad den gör, vi vill jobba med de som är bäst på det de gör.
Och det är sjukt dyrt att ha de som är bäst på det de gör inhouse hela året om.
Kan vi istället ha dem som konsulter typ oktober till november eller september till oktober beroende på vad det är för roll, så kan vi se sjukt bra ut trots att de inte ligger på länelistan 24-7.
Vad är det ni sköter inhouse?
Vad är viktigt att ha inhouse tycker du?
Bra fråga för oss igen.
En viss del av produkten har vi inhouse, alltså produktutveckling.
Jag tror det är jätteviktigt, vi behöver ha kontroll över det.
Sen har vi partner både i Hongkong och i Kina som vi jobbar tight med.
Och sen har vi fabrikerna som nästa lager.
Där till exempel, vi skulle inte anställa någon i Kina för att hälsa på alla fabriker, men vi har faktiskt en som jag har jobbat med i fem år nu nästan, som är också delägare som är i ett Hongkongbolag och en vän som kan vara på plats.
Sen är det ju en brandidentitet och en viss typ av marknadsform.
Jag tror att vi behöver vara kravställande mot konsulter, så det vi egentligen har i typ alla av oss som jobbar med.
Det var en jävla bra mening, får jag bara säga.
Fan, jag gillar det.
Ni behöver ha kompetensen för att kunna kravställa mot konsulter.
Ta åt er det ni som lyssnar.
Precis, istället för att ha Teams, där varje person, oavsett om det är B2B eller om det är produkt, har ett internt team, så är man rätt ensam i sitt team och sen har man ett par konsulter under som man kravställer mot.
Det är typ så organisationen är uppbyggd i nuläget.
Vår ekonomi, till exempel vi har en CFO, men han har ju vår redovisningsbyrå.
Vi har en som är ansvarig för distributörer och retailersälj.
Han har ju distributörer, han kravställer.
Marknadsföringen har sina.
Till och med vår brandactivation manager nu som är med i de nya rollerna, jobbar med att ha lokala activator på plats som hon då kravställer vidare.
Jag tror att det är viktigt, för då kan man skruva upp och ner på de där kranarna.
Hur hanterar ni försäljning utomlands?
Du sa att nu är ni öppna för hela Europa.
Jag vet inte hur mycket ni har hunnit med på den här tiden, men ni har ju ett ganska brett sortiment av vissa produkter som du säger.
Den här bollen kanske väger 900 gram eller 700 gram, men en sån där IR-bastu är ju två pall och 450 kilo, två kubik.
Kan ni sälja allt till alla marknader?
Hur har ni hanterat logistiken och lönsamhetsutvecklingen?
Vi kravställer på våra partners.
Ja, men då så.
Nej, det är spugt.
Nej men vi har en 3PL, en 3D-partslogistik, som hjälper oss med det.
Vi har en partner i Norden som bygger upp produkterna åt oss när vi behöver.
Sen sålde vi till någon, utan att liksom, vi sålde till en väldigt stor profilerad fotbollsspelare i Spanien som fick till exempel en Hyperberg Oxygen Chamber, som också hade liksom, det var lite relationsbyggande där också.
Det var en bekant till Alvaro Morata som vi jobbar med, som sen kände sig lite för svårt att bygga upp den.
Då fick vi flyga ner två pers till Madrid och fixa det.
Det var ändå en bra order och det var relationsbyggande.
Men i grunden, jag tror mycket Gravställas ser till.
Jag tycker att vi ska alltid tjäna pengar på varje produkt vi säljer, och vi ska alltid tjäna pengar i alla marknader vi säljer.
Så om det är så att min medgrundare som hans för supply säger hej det kostar så här mycket den här marknaden, då tycker jag det är enkla svar till sättet.
Sätt ett fraktpris som gör att det är värt att sälja.
Och nu säljer vi till 10-20-tal marknader per dag.
Många av dem säljer vi en produkt styck.
Men det blir ju många bäckar små.
Till och med har man sånt, floden börjar ju någonstans av små floder som kommer in.
Sen är det någon ström som är större.
Sverige är fortfarande vår största flod.
Men sen kommer Norge ganska fint där som en fjällbäck.
Medan Rumänien har vi sålt lite till.
Kommer kanske som en liten pöl som går in.
Men jag tror att man ska inte bara sälja för att sälja, det tror jag är så jävla viktigt.
Man ska tjäna pengar när man säljer.
Annars jobbar man inte bara i sälj, det är också kundtjänst, det är produkterna, det är lagerbindning, det är så många som bara jagar omsättning.
Eller framförallt historiskt har det varit det.
Man får inte glömma, det är inget välgörande arbetet att dra med bolag.
I slutan måste man tjäna pengar på varje kund.
Annars är det onödig tid för alla.
Vilket land är det som har namnat er mest?
Vart märker ni att ni har bäst marknadsfritt?
Finns det något land som ni har märkt att fan, det är inte ens värt att satsa där?
Norge är ju väldigt tacksamt.
Där har vi lagt lite energi men fått väldigt bra resultat.
Danmark är ett land som är vår tredje största marknad, men vi har lagt sjukt mycket tid där.
Men Norge bara seglade om från ingenstans och blev mycket bättre.
Det är lite svårt, för Norge är lite svårt med tull och annat skit.
Det gör att många inte vill gå in på den marknaden.
Det gör det ofta lättare.
Nu ser jag lite UK som samma sak.
Vi sålde ingenting där för ett år sedan.
Nu har vi öppnat upp.
Vi fick sjukt bra intresse från väldigt stora retailers där.
Nu är det vår fjärde största marknad, största utanför Norden, det här första kvartalet.
Det är väl en sådan del, men det är också, ska jag vara ärlig och säga till dig, den enda marknaden just nu, om man går tillbaka till resa tidigare, som inte har lönsamhetskrav på sig.
Alla marknader, alla produkter har lönsamhetskrav på sig, förutom UK, för där tror vi strategiskt att om vi lyckas i UK så är det nyckeln till dels USA, men också resten av Europa.
Så där satsar vi lite mer med klassisk marknadsföring, PR, vi har en byrå på plats, vi har en agent på plats, vi har också dedikerad budget till marknadsföring på stora konton nu under början på året för att bevisa oss att vi kan få större ordrar och hamna inståd för julförsäljningen.
Har ni en 3PL-lösning som hanterar allting mot England och Norge?
Det är inte som du säger, det är inte oss media marknader.
Hur har ni löst den här etappen?
Gravställda, där ska jag.
Vi jobbar med en 3PL bara.
Så det är ju det säger berättaren om vårt behov liksom.
Jag tror att det är så.
En grej som jag märkte, lite på bolagsbyggande, är att förvånansvärt ofta, det här är inte bara bolagsbyggande, det är liksom generellt, för att man ofta är inte nöjd, så söker man sig någon annanstans.
Det första när man inte är nöjd, är att gå och förklara till den partner man har, varför man inte är nöjd och vad man förväntar sig.
Och ge dem en chans att fixa det.
Och väldigt ofta så blir det bättre.
Och de kommer kunna göra det.
Och det är det vi har gjort, vi har kollat på disk och har lokala warehouses och så vidare, men det gör till för massa komplexitet.
Det är väl en sån sak som jag också har haft med mig nu sedan förut, det är att jag vill kunna förstå organisationen, jag vill kunna förstå verksamheten, jag vill att alla internt ska kunna fatta det och jag vill att vi ska kunna vara så effektiva som möjligt.
Så jag har verkligen försökt att ta bort så mycket komplexitet som möjligt och uppmana alla andra att göra också.
För det är en jäkla operational killer alltså.
Att sitta i en massa, ja, sitta och fördela lager på olika ställen och så vidare.
En grej som jag tycker är intressant, och jag ska se hur vi ska få detta att låta bra eller något.
Men vi sågs på en middag på D-Congress och då snackade vi lite grann om Flowlife och vi, alltså gymkompaniiet då, har ju också kikat lite grann på, jag kallar det för återhämtning för att det är så jag ser på det i huvudet eller det är så jag benämner den kategorin.
Men jag har inte riktigt sett den kategorin som en tillräckligt stor kategori eller som tillräckligt etablerad vad man ska fokusera på.
Om vi tar rörljus till exempel, det finns flera bolag i Sverige som har bränt sig på rörljus, medan ni säljer rörljus och verkar få till det.
Och jag ser det lite grann som att ni, alltså lite grann går i täten när ni gör era satsningar.
Jag håller koll på er eftersom ni är semi i vårat segment på något sätt.
Så kika på vad ni lanserar.
Är du rädd för när alla andra aktörer kommer in i er segment så småningom?
För att nu finns det ju några som har testat.
Vi tar rörljus för att det är enklast då.
De har testat, de har gått på en it.
Ni har lyckats komma igång och då kanske folk ser såhär, ja okej, nu börjar det bli etablerat att man kan testa.
Då kanske det kommer en massa fler konkurrenter.
Vad är faran med att ligga där i framkant och hålla på och göra IR-bastu?
Det är inte standard än men det kanske blir standard och då kanske det börjar bli jävligt jobbigt när Bauhaus börjar ta in IR-bastu.
Hur bemöter ni det?
Hur gör ni varumärket?
För det måste ni leta upp tusen nya produkter varje år.
Hur går tankarna?
Jag är bara nyfiken.
Jättebra fråga och nån som har med oss, nu har vi gjort det här i tio år.
Vi har jobbat med allt från Olympiska kommittén till Stockholm Marat och i Sverige har vi gjort så extremt mycket.
Så vi har ett brand så att när det handlar om produkter som kostar en hel del så har vi förtroende från kunden vilket är väldigt starkt.
Det blir rätt svårt att konkurrera med oss som ny om man inte har något väldigt unikt.
Det har ju kommit upp konkurrenter med rätt bra namn, duktig performance marketing.
Jag brukar kalla det första som händer när någonting kommer att trenda.
Det gjorde vi med massagepistoler.
Jag tror vi hade fyra fem konkurrenter i Sverige, alla är borta.
Det hände med rödljus, de kommer och försvinner också.
Så fort det blev trendigt.
Det kallar liksom lyckosökarna.
Det är de som är en e-handelsaktör, de ibland har ett stort namn, de kör en massa marknadsföring, de växer och köper på sig en massa, så länge det är lönsamt.
Sen kommer en vändning för det sker alltid cykler och det sker alltid mättnade marknader.
När den kommer i deras annonsering, inte i lönsamt längre, så går de ofta på en hit och sen försvinner de, så gör de någonting annat.
Det vi gör då är att vi försöker redan vara redo på att vara i nästa kategori.
Så det är fas ett, fas två, som är nästan mer utmanande annars, det är när lågprissegmentet kommer in.
Det är det som hände oss typ 2022 av en stor läxa från det.
Vi hade jättebra B2B-siffror, vi sålde massagepistoror till alla, och sen inför nästa Q4, högsäsong, så visade alla, alltifrån Power till Shell & Company, till flera åter försäljare, hade skapat egna brands och kopierat det produktutbudet vi hade för att märkta och tjäna pengar på det.
Det är nästa del i den här.
Det vi gör då är att dels se till att vi inte konkurrerar på samma prispunkt, utan vi accepterar att det finns ett low-end segment i det vi gör.
Vi är en mid premium, vi brukar kalla det affordable premium.
Det är riktigt bra grejer för ett rimligt pris utan lex, men ändå riktigt bra grejer med en premiumkänsla.
I det här måste man förstå att de här cyklerna sker.
Jag skulle aldrig gå in i ett segment och lägga alla bets på ett segment längre.
Det gjorde vi förut.
Vårt bästa säljeår, trots att vi inte omsatte det mest, ska vi nog säga ändå var, 2021, så vi sålde massagepistoler för 50 miljoner plus, bara massagepistoler.
Det är visst inget segment som vi säljer så mycket av nu.
Det är ingen segment jag förväntar mig att sälja så mycket av nu, utan det finns en mycket, mycket större rimlighet i att jag vill ha tre, fyra segment som står för 20 procent var, och sedan vill jag ha tre, fyra till som står för resterande 20.
Vissa som är relativt små nu kan bli stora till nästa år.
Att de har cykler, typ rödljus, det kanske inte är super, super relevant i juli, i alla fall inte till samma nivå som det är november.
För rödljus för mig, det finns ju massan det är några, men för mig är det en gärna lifesaver vintertid för att köra på morgonen, för att reglera dygnsrytmen.
Så det finns ju alla hudfördelar och liksom återhämtning också.
Men för mig har det varit liksom en lifesaver.
Men då kanske istället vi kommer in i vår kallbad, och de brands som vi ofta möter är inte helt redo på cykler och har inte produkter som backar upp, både konjunktur, säsong och trendcykler som ändå sker.
Vi var också med i, jag bara tänker att jag kan berätta som curiosa, vi var ju också med i den här massagepistols-hypen såklart.
Jag vet inte, har du varit på Fibo någon gång?
Det är en stor träningsmässa i Tyskland, det är alla gymbolag åker.
Och då var ju liksom varannat stånd att de lockade in dig med massagepistoler, de gav en sån här massage när du gick förbi, och sen alla sålde ju massagepistoler.
Helvete vad det var tryggt.
Och vi köpte också in massagepistoler såklart under eget märke.
Jag tror vi sålde ganska bra ett år och sen var det, vi har fortfarande kvar, vad är jävla, vi har försökt jobba med dem i fyra år, det är helt omöjligt.
Alltså det var verkligen en helt galen hype under en period och sen tog bränd i sig flera aktörer och försökte sälja ut restlager.
Det är ju bara intressant hur de här cyklerna funkar, som du säger, det kom ju lågprisaktörer som sålde för några hundra lappar.
Ja men till och med vi hade en kampanj med en återförsäljare där vi sålde ett par tusen massagekuddar.
Det var en superbra kampanj men då använde de ju vår massagekudde och sen bandlade de den med sin massagepistol.
På så sätt kunde de sälja massagepistoler genom att glida på vårt brand men jag tror man får se sin plats, det finns saker man kan förändra som bolagsbyggare, men som måste vara realistiskt med vad man är.
Det är klart att vi går runt på kontoret med superhöga huvudar och är jättestolt över det vi gör.
Men i verkligheten så är vi en rätt liten aktör ur ett nationellt eller globalt perspektiv.
Vi är en lösning på ett problem för kunden men vi behöver hela tiden rättfärdiga vår existens för dem.
Då måste vi ha rätt pris, rätt produkt, vi måste hänga med tiden som sker.
När allt händer med AI och allt förändras extremt snabbt så brukar jag säga att kroppen är en konstant.
Vi jobbar mot samma sak.
Det är kul, kroppen är en konstant.
Om tio år kommer jag att få ändra den för då kommer vi inte vara konstant längre.
Men iallafall just nu är kroppen en konstant och all teknik är flyktig, och liksom frändlig och supersnabbrörlig.
Så vi måste hela tiden se till att vi utvecklar tekniken.
Men syftet är hela tiden samma.
Om man ska kunna lita på att Flowlife är längst fram i den utvecklingen.
Kan du berätta lite om vad ni gör nu under 2026?
Vart ligger ni i kurvan?
Vad är de stora satsningarna?
Vad är det som är intressant just nu?
Nu är det mycket annorlunda med expansion, det är huvudfokuset.
Vi har satt en strategisk marknad att satsa på, det är UK.
Anledningen till det är att vi på väldigt kort tid kom in på tre av deras största återförsäljare.
Vi kom in på John Lewis, som är deras varehus, som är åtta gånger större än O'Leons.
Vi kom in på Curris, som är deras Consumer Electronics, som det heter typ Elgianten, de äger Elgianten till exempel.
Helt enorm också.
Sen håller vi på nu att öppna upp på Boots, som är deras apotek, som också är helt enormt.
Så vi fick liksom lids in dit, alla var superintresserade, de har köpt in produkter.
Så vi lägger väldigt mycket på att hjälpa dem att få proof of concept, på att vi är en aktör som att leka med och spela med.
Så det är liksom del ett.
Och sen för att kunna finansiera det här, och det här är alltid såhär, vi är på lärde i att driva bolag.
Du har något såhär superstrategiskt, men skulle vi bara lägga fokus här skulle vi återigen bränna alla pengar.
Jo men då måste vi ju vara superlönsamma i Norge, vi måste göra en bra affär i Sverige.
Och sen även resten av Europa var tillgängliga för förköp.
Så vi växer jättebra i Spanien, Tyskland, Nederländerna och ser till att finnas där kunderna är.
Hur har ni lyckats göra, och jag menar detta på det mest kärleksfulla av alla sätt, absolut ni är ett framgångsigt bolag, men så jävla stora är ni ju inte.
Alltså ni är inget miradbolag, men ni har gjort en del sjuka samarbeten som Olympiska kommittén var med där ett tag, och nu som du säger, ni kommer in här i England och direkt drar de här samarbetena.
Vad är det som gör att ni får den kopplingen?
Hur gör ni relationsbygget där, eller kontakterna?
Vi är rätt opportunistiska på många sätt.
När det dyker upp en möjlighet så är vi till att springa på den.
Vårt största samarbete hittills var ju Alvaro Morata.
Då var det ju faktiskt att han var sugen på den här typen av produktlinjer, han hade funderat på att göra någonting eget, kände att han kanske inte kunde göra det helt själv, försökte hitta ett bolag som låg i linje med den profilen han hade, och sen hittade de oss att kontakta oss, så vi gjorde en produkt tillsammans.
Med flera utan att nämna namn, för vi är dialoger, vi pratar med några av världens största sportklubbar nu, vi pratar med några av världens största atleter och profiler, och vissa av dem kommer vi inte hitta någonting med här idag, vissa kanske hittar någonting om ett, två år, men vi är duktiga på vad det är, berätta om vår ambition och att vi är långsiktigt, och faktiskt fysiskt träffa folk, ta möterna.
Så där sa jag innan mina kollegor åkte ner till Madrid och träffade en av de största fotbollspelarna, legendarna i världen, som har jättemycket kopplingar till, med det allma vridd där nere.
Men det är aldrig någon som har ringit mig från de här jävla sportklubbarna och vill prata med mig.
Varför ringer de er?
Du får börja gå in och kolla kundlist om vilka er som köper med dig.
De ligger där och gömmer sig.
Jag fattar, jag fattar.
Vi är ju i en nisch där, Recovery Tech är ett litet nisch, fortfarande globalt.
Det är inte jättestort.
Vi är störst i Europa på det vi gör just nu.
Det är väl det som är fördelen.
Jag är en gammal svensk hiphop-fan.
Jag kommer inte ihåg Vendemonde, det var Timbuktu.
Sen så hällde det Kung i Göteborg och en prins i Paris.
Det ligger något i det.
Vi är kungar av Recovery Tech, men vi hade inte ens varit prinsar i träningsbranschen.
Det hade vi varit i bästa fall knäckta.
Vill man jobba med Recovery Tech så är vi väldigt långt fram.
Sen är det en väldigt liten nisch.
Men det gör att vi inte konkurrerar med deras andra samarbetsavtal.
Det är en udda slutsfråga här.
Varför går det så bra för Polen?
Inte i fotboll utan det är en jävla tillväxt i Polen.
Känner du av det eller har du en väldigt patriotisk familj?
Varför satsar ni inte mer i Polen?
Varför säljer ni inte grejer där?
Jag tycker verkligen att vi borde göra det.
Polen är en så intressant marknad och det är jättemånga svenskar som börjar kolla dit nu.
Jag kollar på Polen nämligen.
Därför har jag kollat lite på den polska marknaden.
Vi pratade faktiskt med en distributör som vi kommer rätt långt med, men sen så flöt ut i sista stund att vi fick lite olika håll.
Polen är jätteintressant, vi säljer den där i Polen.
Det är dock intressant, det finns rätt mycket svenska fotbollsspelare i Polen.
Det börjar med att de köpte och sen spridit sig i fotbollsvärlden där.
Men varför går det bra för Polen?
Ett, tror jag att det finns en revanschlust.
Polen har tidigare varit, det är Ukraina nu, alltså slagpåsen bland öst och väst.
Nu har Polen möjligt att bygga upp sig starka.
Det finns en stark känsla av att vilja bevisa sig.
Jag tror det är lite samma sak som jag känner, andra generationens invandrare, man växte upp med folk som hade det kanske starkare finansiellt och man har sett att det går.
Jag tror den drivkraften är väldigt stark i Polen och ekonomiskt sett så är det ju någonting, när det rör sig framåt så går det ofta väldigt bra för landet.
Jämför Polen med typ Japan, som man nu, Polen går ju om Japan i GDPs produktion totalt från att vara kanske en tredjedel för 25 år sedan.
Så det finns en form av optimism av att röra sig framåt.
Sen när andra länder kanske har tappat så har Polen satsat väldigt mycket.
Det är en form av hubby, återigen, fast i ett positivt sätt.
Kina till exempel byggde järnvägshubbar i Polen så att de kunde åka direkt via Ryssland nu, inte ens använd, men tankar om vad som skulle vara som nya Silk Road och även Collor, T-Mobile och de här stora aktörerna.
De bygger ju sina centrallager där.
Jag tror att det finns en jävla vilja att utvecklas.
Jag är också skittaggad.
Vi kan prata om Polen expansion i nästa fas eller komma tillbaka när vi liksom...
Om två år kommer vi se.
Vem lyckades i Polen?
Jag tror att folk underskattar det.
När covid slog till och det inte gick att producera någonting, eller det gick att producera men det var svårt att köpa från Asien, då köpte vi in massa från Polen.
För det var de som liksom steppade upp och började lösa produktion snabbt.
Det var liksom lite andra mått och det var liksom lite andra grejer, men de var liksom, de var där på bollen och började producera.
Jag hade gärna velat sälja i Polen, men det är en lite knepig marknad.
De har väl en marknadsplats som inte är med sådant, utan som är typ Aldi eller något sånt här tror jag.
Ja, men jag har bara märkt när man reser nu.
Alltså, föresåg aldrig polacker när vi var ut och restade.
Det var ju tyskar, det var engelsmän.
Nu, det känns som vart jag än reser så är det bara en massa polacker.
Det finns en helt ny generation.
Sen i Polen också, det är lite som i USA, det är lite tudelat mellan liberalt och konservativt.
Så det är mycket som händer i det landet.
Ena sidan är väldigt, väldigt europavänliga, medan andra är mer stängda.
Så det kan vara väldigt stor skillnad på vem man träffar.
Men nej, jag är jättetvackad på att lansera i Polen.
För jag åker och hälsar på det lite ofta på släkt och så vidare också.
Ja, svär, det var inte det vi skulle hamna om, men jag bara tyckte det var intressant.
Lucas, vilken, jag tror jag sa detta förra gången också, vilken jävla resa ni har gjort och vilket jävla liv du får leva genom bolaget.
Sjukt spännande.
Jag önskar er verkligen allt väl.
Jag tycker ni gör ett jävla grymt jobb och det är sjukt fascinerande att ta del av dina tankar.
Så tack för att du var med.
Tack Joel, det samma.
Och sjukt tacksammast för att vara första personen som får komma tillbaka en gång till.
Och det är sjukt kul.
Nu får man inte hylla dig i din podd, Siru, men det är sjukt kul att du pratar.
Det blir intressanta perspektiv på saker.
Och jag tror inte man behöver, det är lätt att komplicera till saker, men egentligen så behöver man försöka göra de enklare, snarare komplicera till dem.
Det är ett tecken tror jag att man inte förstår att man gör saker för komplext.
Jag håller med.
Tack.
Jag har träffat en av de största fotbollspelarna som är legendär i världen, som har jättemycket kopplingar till rejält att vrida ner.
Men det är aldrig någon som har ringit mig från de här jävla sportklubbarna och vill prata med mig.
Varför ringer de till?
Det får vi börja gå in och kolla.